[Musique]
bonjour à tous c'est un débat
d'actualité que vous allez pouvoir
suivre ce matin un débat sur les effets
de la loi de 2007 sur le service minimum
alors qu'une grève de la sncf provoque
de nombreuses perturbations du trafic
depuis deux jours votée en 2007 cette
loi sur le service minimum dans les
transports avait pour objectif de
prévenir les conflits et de garantir un
service réduit pour les usagers même en
cas de grève
alors le service minimum est il
suffisamment appliquée dans les
transports sept ans après le vote de
cette loi
où en est on tout de suite toutes ces
questions seront abordées dans ce débat
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
la séance et reprise l'ordre du jour
appelle le débat sur l'application de la
loi du 21 août 2007 sur le dialogue
social et la continuité du service
public dans les transports terrestres
réguliers de voyageurs devant de la
commission sénatoriale pour le contrôle
de l'application des lois
la parole est à monsieur jean bernard
magnier au nom de la commission
sénatoriale pour le contrôle de
l'application des lois
merci monsieur plus
c'est président monsieur le ministre
madame la présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales madame monsieur le
rapporteur chers collègues je voudrais
d'abord excusé ici le président david
assouline qui a été de manière tout à
fait fortuite obligé de partir
rapidement et qui m'a demandé en tant
que membre de la commission oui
contrôler l'application des lois
d'intervenir à sa place en ce début de
séance
donc le texte que je vais vous lire lui
appartient je voulais simplement
l'interprète le débat de contrôle qui
s'engage aujourd'hui aurait dû être
organisé plus tôt dans la scission mais
les aléas du calendrier parlementaire
ont contraint à le différé de plusieurs
mois
le hasard veut qu'il ouvre qui s'ouvre
le jour même où un préavis de grève
vient d'être lancé par plusieurs
syndicats de cheminots
les deux questions ne sont pas liées
certes mais notre débat va nous
permettre de faire le point sur un sujet
politiquement sensible et qui concerne
tous les usagers du transport public
fidèle à la tradition
je laisserai le prise dans un swing
l'aurait fait à nos deux rapporteurs de
soin de présenter leurs conclusions sur
cette loi du 21 août 2007 sur le
dialogue social et la continuité du
service public dans les transports
terrestres de voyageurs un intitulé
ambitieux mais qui comme le montre bien
le rapport de même pas ce qu'est
monsieur laménie n'a pas eu la portée
que certains auraient souhaité en
particulier contrairement à une opinion
trop souvent répandue cette loi de 2007
n'a pas instauré d'obligations de
service minimum en cas de grève
d'où un malentendu entre les usagers et
les grandes entreprises de transport
comme la sncf et la ratp
une différence entre l'objet supposée
d'une loi et sa portée juridique réel
c'est typiquement un problème que
qualité normative thèmes auxquels notre
commission accorde une grande attention
nous aurons d'ailleurs l'occasion de
l'approfondir ici même dans quelques
jours lors du débat sur le bilan annuel
de l'application des lois la loi de 2007
illustre bien les difficultés auxquelles
législateur peut être confrontée pour
transcrire en droit les objectifs qu'il
s'assigne
en l'occurrence mieux garantir la
continuité du service public des
transports terrestres ainsi le parlement
a dû trouver le chemin très étroits
entre un principe constitutionnel
intangible le respect absolu du droit de
grève
des résistances psychologiques bien
compréhensible liée à la forte
sensibilité des organisations syndicales
à tout ce qui touche à la négociation
collective l'équilibré économique des
grandes entreprises de transport ce qui
impactait de dispositif de remboursement
des prix des titres de transport en cas
d interruption prolongée du service et
bien entendu la continuité du service
public qui elle aussi est un principe de
valeur constitutionnelle et surtout la
première exigence des usagers j'aurais
également dû évoquer la position
délicate des collectivités territoriales
et de l'état
souvent pris entre deux feux lors ce
lors de conflits sur lesquels et n'ont
guère de prise face à de telles
contraintes
la marge de manoeuvre du législateur
était donc assez réduite
c'est la raison pour laquelle la loi de
2007 ne pouvait avoir qu'une entre
guillemets ambitions limitées pour
reprendre l'euphémisme utilisé par nora
porter sur le plan de sa mise en
application du non terre la loi de 2007
n'a pas nécessité beaucoup de décret et
n'a pas eu à pâtir de retard particulier
en termes d'application des lois on
notera le décret du 24 janvier 2008
intégré depuis lors dans le code des
transports présentait une certaine
sécurité car son intervention ne
devenait nécessaire qu'au cas où les
entreprises concernées n'auraient pas
signé d'accords cadres et ne relèverait
pas d'un accord de branche
c'était si j'ose dire un décret à
parution conditionnelle le législateur
ayant jugé préférable de confier à la
négociation collective le soin de fixer
les modalités d'application de la loi
pourtant si la loi c'est formellement
bien appliqué comme en convient le
rapport il serait excessif d'en déduire
qu'elle donne toute satisfaction aux
différentes parties en présence
les rapporteurs points ainsi les
critiques adressées temps vers les
partants par les employeurs que par les
syndicats et admettent qu'il est très
difficile de mesurer l'impact réel
la loi de 2007 sur le niveau de
conflictualité dans les transports
terrestres
du côté des usagers les échos ne sont
guère plus favorable
le président assouline à plusieurs
reprises rappelé à cette tribune que nos
débats de contrôle sur la législation en
vigueur ne devait pas réitérer le débat
législatif
aussi nous garde aurais-je de revenir
sur l'opportunité d'une loi qui on s'en
souvient répondait sur tout à une
promesse électorale
la rapporteur au sénat notre collègue
catherine procaccia souligné ainsi dès
le début de son rapport qu'il s'agissait
de entre guillemets jlassi traduire un
engagement fort du président de la
république au cours de la campagne
électorale
mais ça rouvre le débat notre travail
d'évaluation notre forte nos forces a
constaté rétrospectivement l'écart assez
nette entre les objectifs affichés par
la loi de 2007 et ses effets réels
c'était car tient en bonne part à une
mesure insuffisante en amont de l'impact
des mesures proposées lors de la
discussion du texte au sénat
plusieurs d'entre nous en avait déjà
souligné les incertitudes je citerai par
exemple notre collègue jean pierre
godefroy qui dénonçaient l'absence d'une
d'une étude d'impact sur les cours des
coûts que subiront les collectivités
territoriales et les entreprises
une fois encore sans entrer dans le fond
du dossier la loi de 2007 nous montre
que pour bien légiférer
le parlement doit pouvoir évaluer sans
précisément assez précisément l'effet
des mesures qui s'apprête à voter
cette démarche ne peut s'organiser dans
la précipitation
quelle que soit la majorité du moment
les assemblées doivent savoir résister à
ce que nos rapporteur qualifie de
propension française à légiférer sous le
coup de l'émotion
quoi qu'il en soit la loi du 21 août
2007 s'applique et nos reporters n'en
propose pas l'abrogation
ils plaident au contraire pour qu'elle
soit mise en oeuvre plus activement
malgré ses lacunes
la loi a permis quelques avancées
appréciables notamment en ce qui
concerne l'information des voyageurs en
cas de grève
en conclusion j'aurais donc tendance à y
voir comme madame basque et monsieur
laménie un texte d'à morse de la
dynamique
og sociale les conclusions et les
préconisations qui devront présenter au
sénat dans quelques instants ont fait
l'objet de débats très consensuel lors
de la discussion en commission
souhaitant qu'elle soit entendue et
qu'elles permettent d'améliorer le
dialogue social dans les transports en
cette période d'inquiétudes exprimées
par les organisations professionnelles
quant aux incidences de la réforme
ferroviaire dans la discussion en séance
publique va commencer dans quelques
jours à l'assemblée nationale je vous
remercie
merci la parole est à monsieur marc
laménie co rapporteur de la commission
sénatoriale pour le contrôle de
l'application des lois
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
madame la présidente de la commission
sur vice président de la commission
sénatoriale d'application des lois mes
chers collègues le 17 octobre dernier
avec ma collègue isabelle le passent
quelques jours
merci vraiment sincèrement et moi même
nous avons présenté devant la commission
sénatoriale pour le contrôler
l'application des lois
notre rapport relatif à la loi du 21
août 2007 sur le dialogue social et la
continuité du service public dans les
transports terrestres eu de voyageurs ce
rapport étaient issus de plus de six
mois de travaux une vingtaine
d'auditions de déplacement l'un à paris
paris nord et l'autre à orléans et à ce
propos réellement sincèrement à celui
les différents administrateurs les
différents services j'irai des deux
commissions pour le travail et travail
de l'ombre travaillent d'efficacité qui
nous a permis aussi parce que j'ai rien
soit un travail pour ne mesurent pas
toujours pour rencontrer des
interlocuteurs des bons interlocuteurs
qui giresse a permis aussi de faire
avancer les choses et on dit toujours
nous apprenons tous les jours je crois
qu'avec ma collègue aussi isabelle
pasquet partagent aussi la passion aussi
des transports ferroviaires en
particulier et je remercie sincèrement
aussi l'ensemble de nos
collaboratrices et collaborateurs donc
je voudrais surtout s'ils ont rappelé
les enjeux et nos principales
constatations avant de laisser la parole
nos collègues isabelle pasquet qui vous
présentera un certain nombre de
recommandations
je dirais que nous avons pu au cours de
ces différentes séances d'auditions et
de travail
j'irai ajusté et et trouvez aussi un
certain nombre de recommandations
comme vous le savez le principe même de
cette loi était selon ses promoteurs de
mieux concilier le droit de grève à la
continuité du service public
deux principes de valeur
constitutionnelle à travers le
développement du dialogue social dans
les transports publics terrestres et
c'est pas simple je lui dis
naturellement en direction de monsieur
le ministre et l'ensemble des services
que giresse et des sujets qui sont très
compliquées ainsi la loi s'applique
uniquement transport terrestre de
voyageurs
c'est à dire aux transports ferroviaires
les tgv on en parle beaucoup mais les
ter aussi avec les collectivités
régionales c'est aussi un sujet
d'actualité
l'e tat trains d'équilibré du territoire
comme les corail qu'il ne faut pas non
plus négliger dans cet hémicycle en
laborde aussi fréquemment certains
collègues aussi interviennent les
transports urbains métro
les tramways et les bus le transport
interurbain notamment les transports
scolaires
didon tous nos départements aussi agir
et qui sont aussi d'importants ce
réellement nous n'avons donc pas abordé
par contre la question du droit de grève
dans les transports aériens qui c'est
aussi un autre sujet de préoccupation et
mais qui ne relève pas de cette loi
ceci dit eu égard aux problématiques
spécifiques soulevées dans le secteur
aérien
ce sujet aussi vraiment qui relève aussi
d'importance mériteraient également une
réflexion approfondie du parlement afin
de répondre aux inquiétudes des
organisations syndicales des salariés
qui nous interpelle aussi chacun et
chacune d'entre nous dans cet hémicycle
contrairement à une idée largement
répandue la loi du 21 août 2007 n'a
jamais eu pour objectif d'instituer un
service minimum dans les transports qui
aurait nécessité la réquisition des
salariés en cas de grève
le législateur en effet choisi la voie
du dialogue social et ces deux mots sont
réellement très fort pour assurer la
continuité du service public en cas de
perturbations prévisibles du trafic liée
à une grève mais aussi à des travaux des
incidents techniques et malheureusement
cela arrive fréquemment ou également des
conditions météorologiques difficiles
pas cet hiver mais les hivers précédents
c'était vraiment pas simple et
l'ensemble aussi des services ont eu
aussi beaucoup beaucoup de mérite
les conditions météorologiques
difficiles pour peu qu'elle soit connue
trente six heures à l'avancé et la météo
la météo n'est pas non plus une science
exacte
le dispositif retenu pour assurer la
continuité du transport repose sur
quatre piliers
tout d'abord la mise en place par accor
dans les entreprises ou à défaut dans
les branches d'un mécanisme de
prévention des conflits qui rend
obligatoire la négociation pendant oui
jours avant le dépôt d'un préavis de
grève sur le modèle de la larme social
on l'a aussi évoqué avec les
représentants de la ratp
puisque c'est existe au niveau de la
ratp depuis 1996 ensuite la définition
des dessertes prioritaire et la
l'élaboration d'un plan de transport
adapté ce qu'on appelle les p&t au plan
de transport adapté et d'un plan
d'information des usagers les pays à
mettre en oeuvre en cas de perturbations
prévisibles
par ailleurs l'obligation pour les
salariés indispensable à l'exécution du
pt a est mentionné dans un accord ou
plan de prévisibilité de déclarer à leur
employeur 48 heures à l'avancé leur
intention de faire grève
enfin dernier point l'amélioration des
droits et l'information des usagers et
c'est vrai que ce volet l'information la
bonne information
c'est réellement la base du tout je ne
reviendrai pas sur la grande diversité
qui règne dans le secteur des transports
publics terrestres de voyageurs qui
étaient soulignés dans notre rapport
même si je n'ignore pas le préavis de
grève déposé par les cheminots de la
sncf notre collègue vient de le rappeler
précédemment des préavis déposés par les
cheminots de la sncf aujourd'hui même
force est de constater que le dialogue
social est globalement davantage
institutionnalisée dans cette entreprise
fait rosiers et ferroviaires que nous
défendons est ainsi qu'à la ratp que
aussi dont le transport urbain et
interurbain
malgré l'absence de statistiques
consolidées au niveau national les
personnes que nous avons pu auditionner
avec ma collègue ainsi que nos
administrateurs s'accorde sur un point
les mouvements sociaux ne sont pas loin
s'en faut
la principale cause des perturbations
prévisibles de trafic enregistré sur les
réseaux de
en sport français une réelle
constatations d'après les informations
que nous avons pu recueillir
ils se situent même en fin de liste
loin derrière les incidents techniques
malheureusement souvent rappelé ainsi
don secours à personne incident
dramatique aussi et les travaux nous le
savons que trop bien dans nos
départements le réseau ferroviaire est
avec ma collègue nous soutenons fils
infrastructures ferroviaires
le réseau ferroviaire est aujourd'hui à
bout de souffle à cause d'un manque
d'investissements manifestent ces
dernières années c'est pas d'aujourd'hui
c'est de nombreuses années en arrière
soit il faut toujours avoir le recul
nécessaire et sentiments de
d'impartialité et c'est souvent rappelé
encore mardi dernier en question
questions orales notre collègue charles
heureux vais vous interrogez monsieur le
ministre sur le département de la seine
maritime sur la sous utilisation des
infrastructures ferroviaires
je le ferai aussi pour déportement je
représente les ardennes on voit aussi
malheureusement des des voies ferrées
qui sont sous utilisées malheureusement
et même des fois des déterreurs qui sont
remplacés par par des lignes de bus
c'est parfois aussi dommage et ce manque
d'envié d'investissement manifestent ces
trente dernières années
on peut naturellement malheureusement le
déplorer le regretter malgré l'effort
sans précédent de réseau ferré de france
pour rénover regénérer le réseau et les
investissements sont considérables à
faire
nous continuerons de pâtir pendant de
nombreuses années encore des
dysfonctionnements aux plantes de notre
sur notre réseau national qui mérite
pourtant aussi beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de soutien une étude est
particulièrement éloquente parmi les 419
perturbations prévisibles
constatée sur le transilien en 2012 plus
de 95 % étaient dus à des travaux et
seulement 3 3% ce qui est vraiment un
film à des mouvements sociaux
cela ne signifie pas que les grèves
n'ont aucun impact sur les usagers ni
qu'il ne faille rien faire pour diminuer
la conflictuelle it et dont le secteur
la relation quotidienne qu'ont de
nombreux français avec les transports en
commun et je crois que c'est aussi au
quotidien qu'il faut vraiment les
soutenir on parle de développement
durable moi je vais aussi vraiment dans
ce sens il ya encore beaucoup beaucoup
de pédagogie à faire beaucoup de travail
à faire la relation quotidienne qu'ont
les français avec les transports en
commun l'insatisfaction qui ressemble
parfois face aux services offerts et se
croient souvent il faut écouter et
entendre aussi les préoccupations des
usagers de nos usagers jeux seront pour
la sncf avec l'éclat de crois que c'est
aussi des lieux d'échangé d'informations
cela explique le caractère souvent
exacerbé de leur réaction en cas de
grève
sur un plan formel la loi a été
correctement appliquée il est vrai
qu'elle ne requérait qu'un seul décret
d'application tri dans le délai imparti
pour définir le contenu de la
négociation préalable au dépôt d'un
préavis de grève pour définir le contenu
de la négociation préalable
en l'absence d'accords d'entreprise ou
de branche les deux rapports au
parlement ont également été remis même
si le second l'a été avec un retard de
deux ans les nouveaux outils de dialogue
social ont bien été mis en oeuvre dans
le secteur du transport urbain un accord
de branche a été signé entre l'union des
transports publics
l'utp et des organisations syndicales
représentatives le 3 décembre 2007 ces
dispositions concorde très largement
avec celle du décret précité surtout
l'accord a instauré un observatoire
paritaire de la négociation collective
et du dialogue social dont les études et
statistiques
se sont révélés précieuse pour notre
travail malheureusement seulement 20 %
des entreprises interrogées par l'utp
déclare avoir signé un accord de
prévisibilité la plupart ayant préféré
recourir un plan unilatéral
la ratp et la sncf ont quant à elles
adaptées à leurs lois leurs mécanismes
de prévention des conflits qui était
auparavant facultatif mais aucun accord
de branche n'a été signé dans le
transport interurbain
en ce qui concerne les entreprises de
transport le processus d'élaboration des
plans de transport adapté des plans
d'information des usagers semblent
désormais arrivé à son terme
bien qu'il ait été plus long que ce que
la loi avait envisagé
s'agissant des autorités organisatrices
de transport la très grande majorité
d'entre elles ont accepté la mission
nouvelle que leur a confié la loi
définir les dessertes prioritaires
assurés en cas de perturbation approuvé
le pt a le pays eut défini par
l'opérateur de transport toutefois
certaines collectivités s'y sont refusés
pour des raisons politiques ou parce
qu'elle avait jugé avoir déjà pris les
mesures appropriées
de fait selon une enquête de l'utp au
moins quinze autorités organisatrices de
transports urbains n'avait toujours pas
défini les dessertes prioritaire en 2012
tandis que 23% des raisons interrogés
n'avaient pas adopté de péter à
c'est également le cas d'un certain
nombre de raisons qui ont la charge des
ter comme l'a prévu la loi le préfet
s'est alors substituer à l'autorité
organisatrice de transport après mise en
demeure
mais la situation n'est malgré tout pas
satisfaisante car le représentant de
l'état n'a ici tu es un rôle supplétif
je vais maintenant céder la parole à ma
collègue isabelle pasquet pour la
représentation de nos recommandations je
vous remercie
merci monsieur laménie la parole est à
mme madame isabelle pasquet co
rapporteur de la commission sénatoriale
pour le contrôle de l'application des
lois
c
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
l'adoption de cette loi a suscité une
opposition forte chez ceux pour qui elle
s'apparente à de nouvelles contraintes
néanmoins les salariés et les
organisations syndicales représentatives
se sont conformés dans leur très grande
majorité aux conditions nouvel exercice
du droit de grève issus de la loi celle
ci n'a donné lieu qu'à un contentieux
limitée qui a permis de préciser ses
modalités d'application ne reste pas
moins que les acteurs concernés nous ont
fait part de nombreux griefs à l'égard
de ce texte
de manière générale la faiblesse du
dialogue social et des tactiques
utilisées par les entreprises pour se
conformer à l'esprit mais non à la
lettre de la loi sont déplorés par les
syndicats ainsi les négociations
préalables dans le cadre de la larme
social serait souvent purement formelle
le rapport de force était toujours
préféré au dialogue
la majorité des concertations préalables
aboutissent en effet un constat de
désaccord
de plus certaines entreprises de
transport urbain n'aurait pas mis en
place de procédures formalisées de
recueil des déclarations préalables
d'intention de faire grève ce qui
compromettrait de secret professionnel
par lequel elles sont couvertes
enfin cette loi aurait indubitablement
transformer l'exercice d'un droit
constitutionnel fondamental le droit de
grève en une affaire de spécialistes
marquant un pas supplémentaire dans la
judiciarisation des relations du travail
de leur côté les employeurs souligne que
la loi ne fait pas de distinction entre
les grèves en fonction de leurs mots
d'ordre qui lorsqu'il est nationale ne
peut être satisfait par l'entreprise
de plus certains estiment que la larme
social est dévoyé car banalisée au
détriment des institutions
représentatives du personnel
enfin il regrette que la cour de
cassation ait reconnu la légalité des
préavis de grève à durée déterminée
de longue durée et des grèves
récurrentes de très courts duré moins
d'une heure dont il estime qu'elles ont
des effets disproportionnés en termes de
désorganisation de l'entreprise
au fil de nos auditions nous avons pu
constater que l'impact de la loi sur la
confidentialité était difficile à
apprécier
du fait notamment du caractère
irrégulier est difficilement prévisible
de la récurrence des mouvements sociaux
l'évolution du nombre de préavis de
grève ou de jours de grève par agent à
la ratp ou à la sncf depuis 2007 ne
semble pas lié à l'adoption de la loi il
n'est pas possible d'établir une
corrélation entre la loi et l'évolution
de la compliquer alité cette dernière
dépendant surtout des mots d'ordre
nationaux
dans ce contexte notre rapport formule
une série de recommandations visant
essentiellement à améliorer
l'application de la loi
il est tout d'abord indispensable de
remettre le dialogue social au coeur de
l'application de la loi
but affiché de ce texte son amélioration
n'a pas été généralisée il faut donc
tirer pleinement partie des possibilités
offertes en associant mieux des
institutions représentatives du
personnel à la définition du plan de
transport adapté et du plan
d'information des usagers surtout la
période de négociation préalable doit
être mise à profit par toutes les
parties pour chercher à éviter le
conflit si elle reste purement formelle
sa valeur ajoutée par rapport au préavis
est inexistante
la revalorisation du dialogue social en
dehors des périodes de conflit est le
seul moyen de parvenir à terme à une
diminution significative du nombre et de
l'intensité des conflits sociaux dans
les transports
ils dopent doivent devenir une démarche
permanente plutôt qu'un ultime recours
lorsque le conflit devient inévitable
les organisations syndicales ne pas
avoir à menacer du dépôt d'un préavis de
grève pour être reçus par la direction
les litiges individuels doivent pouvoir
être résolu par d'autres biais que la
lame sociale il faut surtout revenir à
l'équilibré votée en 2007
cela passe par la suppression des
modifications en porte à porte et en
2012 par la loi dia en application de
celle ci les salariés qui avaient
l'intention de faire grève doivent
informer 24 heures à la baisse leurs
employeurs s'ils renoncent ou pour ceux
qui étaient en grève s'ils souhaitent
reprendre le travail
la stabilité des règles considère la
défense des intérêts professionnels des
salariés et la sauvegarde de l'intérêt
général doit être recherchée la loi
diarrhée venus l'a perturbé avec un
effet contraire à celui initialement
recherché puisque un salarié peut être
artificiellement forcer à faire grève 24
heures de plus qu'ils ne l'auraient
souhaité le deuxième volet de nos
recommandations portent sur la
responsabilisation des autorités
organisatrices de transport celles ci
doivent s'investir davantage dans la
définition des dessertes prioritaire en
cas de perturbations elles peuvent agir
par ce biais pour corriger des
inégalités territoriales ou garantir que
des services prioritaires soient
correctement desservi
il est également important qu'elle
approuve le ptr et le pays
préparé par l'entreprise de transport le
cas échéant en demandant des
modifications surtout elles doivent
intégrer des critères sociaux et
environnementaux de qualité de service
dans les conventions d'exploitation
qu'elle conclue avec les entreprises de
transport prévu par l'article 12 de la
loi
cette mesure est jusqu'à présent restée
lettre morte
seul le stif s'en est saisi pour les
contrats signés avec la ratp et la sncf
en 2012 l'état a ôté des trains
d'équilibré du territoire est en retard
sur ce point tout comme de nombreuses
régions par cette disposition la haute
et pourrait garantir des acquis sociaux
en particulier lorsque le recours à la
sous traitance est très répandue les
possibilités sont également nombreuses
sur le plan environnemental la
systématisation des bilans d'exécution d
péter à aider pays
ainsi que leur contrôle par la route et
doit être l'occasion pour cette dernière
d'évaluer les choix de l'entreprise de
transport l'intérêt ici n'est pas
uniquement de faire un bilan comptable
de la mise en oeuvre d'un pt à la haute
et doit être à même d'identifier
l'origine de toutes les perturbations et
en cas de grève de comprendre pourquoi
la procédure de prévention des conflits
a échoué
il nous est également apparu important
de développer des outils statistiques
harmonisées de suivi des perturbations
du trafic de l'application de la loi
à titre d'exemple sncm ne dispose pas de
statistiques consolidées sur les
principales causes de perturbations
prévisibles du trafic recensées sur un
réseau une typologie précisé uniforme
doit donc être réalisés à l'échelle
nationale le secteur du transport
interurbain doit faire un effort
particulier il a échoué à conclure un
accord de branche sur la prévention des
conflits et ne dispose d'aucun outil
statistique fiable le dialogue social
dans la branche de donc reprendre et la
fédération professionnelle concernée la
fntv doit assurer le suivi de
l'application de la loi
enfin il est temps que le gouvernement
s'assure que cette loi soit uniformément
appliquée sur tout le territoire
le ministère des transports devrait donc
réaliser un recensement des p&t a&p eu
pour obtenir un bilan exhaustif de ceux
ci sur cette base un travail de
sensibilisation des outer et de partage
de leurs initiatives pourraient être
entrepris la conciliation de deux
principes institutionnels
apparemment contradictoires comme la
comptine continuité du service public et
le droit de grève
la boutique inévitablement un résultat
qui ne satisfait pas pleinement tous les
acteurs concernés qu'ils soient plus
favorables à l'un ou à l'autre de ces
droits
néanmoins ils se sont approprié la loi
du 21 août 2007
réponse sans doute imparfaite au
problème plus vaste de la qualité du
service dans les transports elle n'en
est pas moins contribué n'en a pas moins
contribué en clash est enclenché la
mécanique
du dialogue social dans le secteur
d'activité il faut désormais poursuivre
dans ce sens afin que les revendications
légitimes des salariés ne soient pas
opposés au droit constitutionnel des
usagers l'édifice a été bâti il
appartient maintenant à tous les acteurs
de faire vivre le dialogue social au
bénéfice du service public
je vous remercie
merci madame dans la suite du débat la
parole est aux orateurs des groupes et à
monsieur jean désessard pour le groupe
écologie
j'avoue bien
monsieur président sur le mini chers
collègues alors celles et ceux qui
étaient là au moment du débat s'était
animée
il y avait de l'ambiance les points de
vue était partagé
bon aujourd'hui c'est plus calme
quasiment consensuelles alors je pense
que la loi s'inspire peut-être davantage
de ce qu'avait dit xavier bertrand que
des intentions belliqueuses du président
de la république
cates qui a été évoqué tout à l'heure
l'objectif du gouvernement selon reprend
enfin l'objectif avoué était triple
selon les mots de xavier bertrand alors
ministre du travail
évitez au maximum le recours à la grève
premier objectif éviter la paralysie en
cas de grève évitée l'absence
d'information pour les usagers ah oui
évitez au maximum leur coin d'accord
parce que ça n'interdit pas in extremis
le droit de grève est là qu il y avait
toute la discussion
est-ce qu'on l'interdise est ou non ce
n'était pas le cas
la grève est une manifestation d'un
conflit social et si on l'on peut la
prévenir c'est qu'une solution
ap trouvait alors là j'ai cru comprendre
mais peut-être que j'ai mal compris que
les rapporteurs nous disent que cet
aspect de la loi est mitigé 1
le bilan sur ce point là c'est mitigé
pas en effet la loi prévoit simplement
la mise en place obligatoire d'une
négociation entre organisations
syndicales et entreprises de transport
avant le dépôt de tout préavis de grève
et si on en arrive à ce stade là c'est
que le mécontentement était déjà bien
ancrée et commencent à se manifester
en fait il est déjà trop tard donc il
faut plutôt favoriser d'autres modèles
de gestion du service public des
transports dot manière d'envisager les
rapports entre les salariés et la
direction le dialogue social se doit
d'être présent à tous les échelons donc
on voit très bien que
ce point le dialogue social dans les
transports publics mise à part dans un
certain nombre d'entreprises où il y à
des modalités de concertation
il reste beaucoup à faire le deuxième
objectif éviter la paralysie en cas de
grève alors si on s'en tient à
l'objectif il est louable mais enfin
faut tout de suite dire et ça a été dit
par mes collègues que les conflits
sociaux ne sont qu'une cause marginale
des retards sur la ligne de transport et
on avait longuement débattu c'est à dire
pourquoi une loi pour 3% des situations
à la ratp pour l'année 2012 dans les
causes de perturber perturbations du
trafic du métro on retrouve avant tout
les causes techniques 43%
les incidents voyageurs 31%
et puis bon ça a été dit par manque de
moyens un an suite à l'accident de
brétigny sur orge
le rapport de l'expert judiciaire nommé
de l'en lors de l' enquête sur les
causes de l'accident se montrent
extrêmement critique quant à la
maintenance des voies par la sncf par
manque de moyens donc voilà c'est
principalement cela les mouvements
sociaux ne sont responsables que de 3%
des perturbations c'est ce qu'on avait
dit à l'époque on avait une loi pour 3 %
des factures massiot 1 dans l'ensemble
des transports urbains le nom deux jours
de grève est relativement faible
seulement 0.49 jours de grève par an et
par salarié en 2011 les 3% de
perturbations la grève sont pointés du
doigt comme étant les sources
principales de nuisance ars il nous faut
vraiment lutter contre la paralysie dans
les transports intérêts ne sont
intéressants nous ne sur le ministre aux
90% aux autres causes qui représente 90
7%
dp
urbas sion donc c'est améliorer la
qualité des réseaux car c'est cela qui
nous réellement envisager les réseaux
vétustes bondé dans les zones à
fréquentation est né alors sur le
dernier objectif et ça a été dit hier
alors par les rapporteurs éviter
l'absence d'information pour les usagers
c'est à dire donner l'information aux
usagers
eh bien je crois il ya eu des avancées
importantes
1 il est primordial que les jasées ne
soit pas bloquée ce1 en région
parisienne grève
d'un seul coup on est arrivé à paris par
le rer 40 km et on est bloqué on sait
pas comment rentrer donc il est évident
qu'il doit y avoir l'information et cela
c'est nécessaire et je pense qu'il ya
des avancées les voiliers de les
voyageurs doit pouvoir s'adapter à
l'avance si des perturbations sont
prévues les réseaux de transport ont
d'ailleurs bien intégré cette impérative
notamment grâce à internet et aux
applications sur tablettes et téléphones
mobiles en communiquant de plus en plus
rapidement
aussi bien sur les grèves que sur les
problèmes techniques et les accidents
alors le dernier point qui avait fait
débat c'était la signature individuelle
et moi je rappellerai que la grève est
non seulement un droit constitutionnel
mais aussi une action collective
il est prévu dans la loi une procédure
de déclaration préalable qui obligeait
salariés à faire part de leur intention
de participer à la grève c'est là que se
situe le vrai danger de la loi dans
l'individualisation de la revendication
sociale
la grève est et doit rester une action
menée par un groupe de travailleurs et
non par une somme d'individus car en
émiettant les responsabilités en tentant
de séparer les travailleurs l'objectif
n'est plus d'éviter le recours à la
grève pour le dialogue social mais de
l'empêcher par la contrainte
la grève doit rester une action
collective
et puisqu'il me reste une minute
monsieur le président je vais faire part
de mon expérience quand j'étais
animateur social et que je travaille
avec les chômeurs et on me disait mais
jean avec l'augmentation des demandeurs
d'emploi y voyant l'explosion sociale
les gens disaient non la france est trop
vieille pour ça va avoir trop souvent le
médecin ont fait plus d'explosions
sociales mais il y aura l'implosion
sociale et l'implosion sociale c'est le
plus la violence dirigée contre le
patronat où l'état où les ministres
l'implosion sociale c'est la violence
dirigés vers soi vers ses proches sur
les suicides les médicaments les
violences conjugales de violence de
voisinage des éruptions va dire assez
difficile dans certains quartiers c'est
ça la clause sociale et j'allais plus
loin c'était maintenant il ya une
quinzaine d'années et j'avais dît si on
répond pas et si on donne pas une
réponse politique c'est assez
désespérant sociale et à cette implosion
sociale
elle aura sa traduction par exemple
pouvait penser que à une époque les
skyzos social sa traduction politique
c'était les partis de gauche et bien la
traduction politique de la désespérance
sociale de l'implosion sociale
c'est au contraire un parti qui
s'appelle le fonds national et déjà
j'avais signalé que si on ne répondait
pas et que s'il n'avait pas
effectivement si on continuait à
émietter a favorisé la souffrance
sociale
on arrivait au fonds national et et
c'est vraiment le danger de ce soir
quand on voit que même les syndicats
sont touchés politiquement par justement
l'émergence du front national c'est
vraiment grave
et justement c'était le danger de cette
loi c'est à dire ne pas favoriser le
combat social collectif mais vouloir
tout individualisé individualiser les
rapports sociaux
ce qu'il y ait fait qu'il n'y a plus
d'esprit sion collective et que dans
l'expression individuelle et bien les
gens dans leur désespérance cherche le
refus le refus ce qu'il pense et un bus
mais qui au contraire ne fera
qu'aggraver la situation
donc je vous remercie et c'était pour
dire que la grève doit rester un moyen
d'action collective en dernier recours
certes mais un moyen d'action possible
et qui peut être utilisé par les
sahraouis
merci monsieur des essarts la parole est
à monsieur 20 quand vincent
capo-canellas ce pour le groupe udc
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
madame et monsieur les rapporteurs mes
chers collègues l'ordre du jour de la
haute assemblée nous livre ce soir un
clin d'oeil que l'on pourrait s'il était
insolent qualifié de pied donné notre
assemblée a souhaité programmer un débat
sur l'application de la loi du 21 août
2007 relative au dialogue social et la
continuité du service public dans les
transports terrestres réguliers de
voyageurs
et ce débat tombe à point nommé puisque
dès que ce débat sera terminée débutera
une grève reconductible à la sncf à
l'appel de deux syndicats de cheminots
opposés à la réforme ferroviaire que
nous examinerons très prochainement dans
cet hémicycle
hasard du calendrier monsieur le
ministre vous aurez l'occasion sans
doute de rassurer les cheminots sur la
réforme ferroviaire
celle ci nous espérons permettra aussi
de moderniser et d'améliorer le service
rendu aux voyageurs
car c'est bien le sujet peut-on en
france pratiquer un dialogue social
autrement que par la seule confrontation
pouvons-nous aller plus loin dans des
logiques de négociation en posant
ensemble avec des organisations
syndicales
les vrais enjeux sans oublier au passage
les voyageurs notre démocratie sociale
doit savoir mieux poser c'est vrai sujet
ce qu'ils font l'avenir des services
publics en oublions pas que le monde est
ouvert et que c'est d'abord en
modernisant sa vie publique que le
dessus sur razon à venir
l'équipe de la loi de 2007 et donc à
saluer comme le font nos rapporteur je
dirais ici quelques mots à la fois de ce
qui est selon moi dans ce rapport est de
ceux qui à juste titre n'y est pas même
si d'aucuns voudraient en faire une
lecture au blick
je pense ici curieusement au syndicat
l'aérien qui font mine d'oublier que ce
rapport concerne les transports
terrestres ce qui est dans le rapport
d'abord reçoit notre accord
un premier principe le dialogue social
est
pourtant il faut toujours le développer
et l'encourager c'est tout l'intérêt de
la loi de 2007 qui est souvent à tort
considéré comme instituant un service
minimum dans les transports en commun
alors qu'un attitude surtout un
dispositif de négociation préalable en
cas de désaccord et de conflits au sein
de l'entreprise
le paradoxe c'est que comme le montrent
nos deux rapporteurs notent 2007
fonctionne et a répondu aux objectifs
qui lui avaient été fixés par le
législateur
convenons que ce soir la démonstration
n'est pas la plus aisée
l'avenir dira si monsieur le ministre
réussi à renouer les fils du dialogue
certes il n'est pas possible d'affirmer
que la loi de 2007 a fait baisser le
nombre de conflits sociaux et de préavis
de grève car foi de statistiques des
opérateurs concernant les principales
causes de perturbation prévue du trafic
personne ne dispose d'un facteur de
corrélation entre les deux phénomènes
comme le montrent nos collègues les
jours de grève dans les transports
terrestres sont liées au mouvement et
mots d'ordre nationaux là où le dialogue
social au niveau de l'entreprise
institué par la loi de 2007 et quasi
inopérant jeu se croire que la sncf est
un contre exemple car elle pratique le
dialogue social
ici je dois dire ma relative
incompréhension avec le mouvement social
en cours il me semble contraire qu' on
pourrait faire le procès aimable au
projet de loi ferroviaire qui à bien des
égards il est soucieux des équilibres
sociaux et peut-être un tout petit peu
moins du besoin d'adaptation au monde
d'aujourd'hui
mais je poursuivrai avec une autre
provocation en rappelant que les
conflits sociaux et là je rejoins les
rapporteurs et les grèves sont une part
minime des perturbations du trafic des
transports de voyageurs
comme l'année montrent précisément le
rapport un effet et je parle
d'expérience en trente ans vous le savez
monsieur ministre le rer b pour me
rendre au sénat et pour rejoindre la
capitale et pour rappeler que nos
concitoyens voient surtout les incidents
accidents retard avarie qui touche les
transports particulièrement en ile de
france et qui pourrissent littéralement
leur vie quotidienne
cela renvoie un débat que nous avons
souvent eu ici
ministre en séance sur l'état du réseau
francilien vous avez bien voulu
m'annoncer une mission sur le rer b
les travaux les difficultés constatées
les suites qui avaient été apportées
j'aurai plaisir à l'occasion à vous lire
bientôt peut-être sur ce sujet seuls
investissements massifs de rénovation et
de modernisation du réseau permettront
d'améliorer à terme les conditions de
circulation de nos concitoyens et je le
crois profondément de rassurer les
salariés sur leur avenir
là est l'enjeu majeur pour l'avenir les
transports terrestres
cela renvoie à nos discussions également
sur le financement des infrastructures
de transport et sur l'éco redevance pour
ne pas dire l'écotaxe dont nous ne
savons pas toujours
à cette heure le sort que le
gouvernement lui réservera contenu des
déclarations il est vrai contradictoires
des ministres concernés et là dessus je
vous crédite me celui d'une forme de
constance sur le sujet la carte et des
financements et des investissements
c'est aussi une clé du dialogue social
affiché une ambition c'est mobilisateur
pour les salariés et pour les voyageurs
comme le montre le rapport
le dispositif inspiré de la procédure
d'alarmé sociale existant préalablement
la ratp fonctionne bien est une avancée
notable pour les usagers grâce au
dispositif de déclaration après la dgre
et vi et de définition des desserts
prioritaire nos concitoyens sont informé
la veille au plus tard d'être acquis
circuleront lendemain de la proportion
des trains des horaires et des lignes
qui seront en service nous le mesurons
se soit particulièrement avant 2007 et
voyageurs ne disposait pas de ces
informations essentielles pour
l'organisation de leur journée il faut
ainsi celle du travail de deux
rapporteurs qui au delà de leur
orientation politique qu'on pourrait
qualifier d'opposer ont réussi à établir
un bilan objectif et juste de cette loi
de 2007
souvent appelé à tort loi sur le service
minimum et aboutir à des positions et
des recommandations communes pour une
loi s'il écrit à l'époque par
l'opposition parlementaire d'alors comme
le dit le rapport l'ordinateur a réussi
à trouver un équilibre entre les deux
principes constitutionnels apparemment
contradictoires du droit de grève
et celui du principe de continuité du
service public
devant l'impossibilité d'instituer un
service minimum dans les transporteurs
de voyageurs qui aurait supposé de
réquisitionner les personnels le
dispositif institué par la loi d'août
2007 réussi à s'inscrire dans le cadre
constitutionnel contre un exercice du
droit de grève et à concilier ces deux
principes par une procédure de
déclaration préalable des salariés et
d'information des voyageurs
le succès de cette loi dans les
transports terrestres se mesure aussi
avec cette duplication en 2012 dans le
transport aérien avec la loi relative à
l'organisation du service et à
l'information des passagers dans les
entreprises de transport aérien dite loi
diard je saisis l'occasion ces
discussions pour évoquer cette loi qui
est en ce moment contestée par certains
syndicats de personnels qui s'appuie à
tort me semble-t-il
et je rejoins en cela mon collègue marc
laménie sur une recommandation du
rapport pour demander son abrogation
si je veux dire un mot de ce qui n'est
pas dans le rapport à juste titre même
si d'aucuns voudraient à tour me
semble-t-il les inclure il faut en effet
préciser que nos deux rapporteurs
n'évoque pas en tant que tel la loi du
19 mars 2012 dit edgar mais uniquement
les dispositions qui ont été ajoutés par
amendement à l'occasion de l'examen de
cette loi
pour compléter la loi 2007 il ne
concerne que les transports terrestres
et nuit et nullement le transport aérien
il s'agit notamment d'une disposition
qui avait été introduite par un
amendement pour régler un mouvement de
grève le cas la sncf et qui oblige le
salarié qui s'est déclaré gréviste a
déclaré 24 heures à l'avant ce soit sa
décision de renoncer à la grève soit
celle de reprendre le travail comme
moment où deux rapporteurs de propose de
supprimer la loi diard mais je les
compris comme tel dû supprimer les
modifications apportées par la loi diard
sous-entendu à la loi du 21 août 2007
il ya donc un certain paradoxe à
s'emparer du rapport comme certains le
font pour lui faire dire ce qu'il ne dit
pas
le rapport ne parle nullement du
dispositif de prévention des conflits
d'information des passagers du transport
aérien puisque ce n'est pas son objet il
ne faut donc pas remettre en cause la
loi d'hyères
c'est l'occasion de se
débat comme la loi de 2007 relative au
dialogue social et la continuité du
service public dans les transports
terrestres la loi diar dans transport
aérien a fait la démonstration son
utilité pour l'organisation des vols en
cas de mouvements de grève et
l'information des passagers tout en
respectant le droit de faire grève et
les droits des personnels aériens
puisqu'elle a été jugée
constitutionnelle cette loi comme la loi
de 2007 pour les transports terrestres
incite au dialogue social et le renforce
dans les transports ce qui correspond
aussi à une option que nous partageons
privilégier la prévention des conflits
plutôt que le conflit et le recours à la
grève qui n'est que le constat de
l'échec du dialogue et de la négociation
et non son préalable l'esprit décès de
loi est bien de favoriser une culture du
dialogue entre les partenaires sociaux
afin d'éviter les conflits et le recours
à la grève
malheureusement utilisé parfois par
certains syndicats comme un préalable à
la discussion
elles sont aussi essentiels pour
l'information des voyageurs et des
usagers ce principe ne peut être remis
en cause
ils se sont habitués à être informé soit
par pour des vols annulés soit pour des
trains circulant à bout ne circulant pas
et du trafic sur les lignes en cas de
mouvement social nos concitoyens ne
comprendraient pas donc l'on revienne
sur cet acquis pour conclure car il faut
bien trouver une solution à leurs
revendications exprimées connexes dans
l'aérien
je ne peux que suggérait à la commission
pour le contrôle de l'application des
lois d'établir un bilan de la loi du 10
mars 2012 pour faire le pendant de ce
rapport je rejoins ici la recommandation
de notre collègue marc laménie et je
m'en réjouis
je vous remercie de votre attention
merci la parole est à monsieur robert
hue pour le groupe rdse
c'est le président monsieur le ministre
madame monsieur les rapporteurs mes
chers collègues
sept ans après l'adoption expéditive de
la loi du 21 août 2007 relative à la
continuité du service public dans les
transports terrestres d'un voyageur un
état des lieux serein sur la
conflictuelle alité au sein des
entreprises de transport devenait
indispensable à la suite des débats
houleux qui se sont tenues au combien
nécessaire qu'ils sont tenus au sénat
puis à l'assemblée nationale
l'opposition était à l'époque justifié
avant tout par les propos qui déformait
la réalité sur les origines des
perturbations dans les transports
fortement relayée par les médias sur ces
mauvais fondement on s'apprêtait à
remettre en cause l'exercice du droit de
grève un droit fondamental difficilement
acquis par les salariés est reconnu par
l'alinéa 7 du préambule de la
constitution de 1946 à valeur
constitutionnelle qui a progressivement
permis à l'ensemble de nos concitoyens
d'obtenir l'amélioration de leurs
conditions de travail ainsi que de leurs
droits sociaux
en 2007 le gouvernement prétendait
encadrer le droit de grève dans les
transports
sous prétexte de garantir la liberté
d'aller et venir
l'accès aux services publics essentiels
la liberté du travail ou encore la
liberté du commerce et de l'industrie
certes dans les transports en commun une
perturbation de quelque nature que ce
soit peut occasionner une gêne
provisoire pour les usagers qui n'ont à
leur disposition d'autres moyens pour se
déplacer
on pouvait cependant s'interroger sur la
pertinence du projet de loi alors que
des progrès avaient avaient déjà eu lieu
au sein
de la ratp depuis 1996 puis de la sncf
par un protocole d'accord signé en 2003
le rapport de la commission sénatoriale
pour le contrôle de l'application des
lois peut légitimement nous conduire à
remettre en question l'utilité même de
ce texte dont l'évaluation n'a pas dû
être aisée la loi at elle aboutit par la
mise en place d'un mécanisme de
prévention des conflits à réduire la
conflit qu alité et à restaurer le
dialogue social
le rapport ne semble pas plaidé en ce
sens c'est mon point de vue le nombre d'
alarme sociale a augmenté les dialogues
entre la direction et les organisations
syndicales de salariés n'ont été
malheureusement que formel et lé constat
de désaccord après négociations se sont
accrus l'évaluation prend l'exemple de
la ratp où 36% des alarmes sociales se
sont soldées par un accord en 2012
contre 56% en 2007 les seuls avantages
que l'on peut retenir de cette loi c'est
l'instauration d'une négociation
obligatoire dans toutes les entreprises
de transport là où elle n'était encore
que facultative et le renforcement de
l'information des usagers lors des
perturbations prévisibles
ce dernier point ne doit toutefois pas
être négligé bien sûr la loi at elle
permis d'assurer une plus grande
continuité des services publics
argument qui tenait lieu de
justification à ceux qui préconisaient
des restrictions du droit de grève
non puisque les usagers subissent
toujours des retards et suppressions de
trains panne de signalisation panne de
cathéters caténaire accident voyageur
présence de colis suspect qui est divers
incidents
combinées les perturbations ça a été lu
par un de mes collègues c'est très
important
les perturbations liées à la grève ne
sont en effet que très marginal puisque
cette dernière n'est à l'origine que de
3 3% des perturbations en moyenne la
très grande majorité relève donc bien
d'incidents techniques
et d'incidents voyageurs nous sommes
bien loin
mes chers collègues des déclarations
souvenez-vous au sein de cet hémicycle
de xavier bertrand alors ministre du
travail qui les trémolos dans la voix
voulez que absolument plus de voyageurs
exaspérés sur les quais guettant un
train qui ne viendra peut-être jamais on
se souvient et contrairement aux propos
provocateurs de nicolas sarkozy en
juillet 2008
la grève dans les transports on s'en
aperçoit encore et j'ajoute que c'est
bien ce texte ne peut donc répondre aux
situations les plus bloquante à savoir
les grèves qui relève des revendications
de politique nationale
ainsi l'origine des perturbations dans
les transports terrestres se situant à
un tout autre niveau de loi n'apportait
qu'une réponse au maire a des problèmes
plus profonds
si la loi de 2007 devait permettre
d'encourager le dialogue social
rien n'a été fait pour régler le
problème à la source c'est-à-dire
améliorer les conditions de travail des
salariés des entreprises de transport et
préserver le service public en accordant
les moyens de financement nécessaires à
la qualité des dessertes les salariés
continuent de subir des agressions des
actes de malveillance et plus
dramatiquement encore les conséquences
de suicides sur les voies
ainsi ce sont les perturbations
imprévisible vous entendez les
guillemets qui pèse sur la vie des
usagers
ce sont les souhaits et les sous
investissements depuis les années 80 qui
sont à l'origine de la très grande
majorité des perturbations et donc de
l'insatisfaction des usagers alors que
la fréquentation a explosé ces dernières
années
cela est particulièrement vrai en
ile-de-france dont la fréquentation du
rer a augmenté de 30% en dix ans rendant
la situation de plus en plus tendues et
insoutenable pour nos concitoyens
d'où l'urgence de rendre pérenne le
financement des infrastructures de
transport à commencer par les recettes
de l' agence de financement des
infrastructures de transport
dont la ressource principale devait être
constitué de l'éco taxe poids lourds
l'absence de visibilité sur ce dossier
mettant en péril le renouvellement des
trains d'équilibré du territoire
monsieur le ministre
j'espère que la réforme ferroviaire que
nous examinerons prochainement plus que
de s'atteler uniquement à l'ouverture à
la concurrence du transport de voyageurs
on risque de mettre en péril l'accès au
service public ferroviaire répondra mais
j'en doute pas efficacement
à la question de son financement merci
la parole est à madame hélène masson
maret pour le groupe ump
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
madame leur apporter à monsieur le
rapporteur l'essence même de la fonction
du parlementaire et d'édicter des lois
mais vérifier la bonne application de
ces lois est un rôle qui me paraît
également primordiale à double titre
tout d'abord la préoccupation principale
consiste à constater s'il existe ou non
un décalage entre ce que le législateur
a voulu et l'application concrète qui
est fait sur le terrain mais il est
également important d'adapter la loi aux
évolutions de notre société
et quand cela est nécessaire d'améliorer
les lois existantes en légiférant à
nouveau pour cette raison l'examen du
rapport sur l'application de la loi des
internautes 2007 80 etc ou tout à fait
particulier à partir d'aujourd'hui ce
mardi à 19h avec la non d'une grève
reconductible à la sncf à l'appel de
deux syndicats de cheminots
le problème des grèves en france est
donc toujours d'actualité et nécessitent
d'étalonner le dispositif de 2007
pourquoi on peut pas imaginer d'autres
sociétés c'est s'étonner d'un attentat
de votre côté avec la mode du trail
reconductible je vous disais donc avant
d'imaginer quelles suites à donner à
cette entreprise d initiative
rappelons en quelques mots les
circonstances qui nous réunit ce soir
dans cet hémicycle le sénat publié un
rapport sur l'application de la loi du
21 août 2007 qui montrent que si
formellement la loi était plutôt bien
accès à plis ké et que les voyageurs
sont désormais mieux informer son impact
sur le nombre de mouvements sociaux
demeurent difficiles à établir et des
griefs à l'égard de cette loi toujours
important et mérite que l'on s'y attarde
rappelons maintenant en quelques mots
les périmètres de cette loi elle
s'applique aux transports ferroviaires
aux transports urbains aux transports
interurbains et concerne opérateurs
publics entreprises privées
internationales et pme rappelons
également en quelques mots aussi les
dispositions introduites par cette loi
elles ont été dites mais c'est toujours
bon de les reporter à porter il ya
quatre piliers je voudrais qu'on les
revoie rapidement donc cette loi a mis
des moyens la mise en place d'un
mécanisme de prévention des conflits qui
rend obligatoire la négociation pendant
huit jours avant le dépôt d'un préavis
de grève
la définition de desserts prioritaires
et l'élaboration d'un plan de transport
adapté connus sont de pt a aidé un plan
de formation des usagers pays pub
l'obligation pour les salariés de
déclarer à leur employeur 48 heures l'as
vence leur intention de faire grève et
enfin l'amélioration des droits et de
l'information des usagers
examinons maintenant ce qu'il me paraît
très important
les contributions du sénat en 2007 à
l'article 1er un amendement duc portelli
est venu préciser le rôle essentiel des
services publics de transports monsieur
le ministre et je le cite
ils permettent la liberté d'aller et
venir la liberté d'accès aux services
publics notamment sanitaires sociaux
d'enseignement la liberté du travail
la liberté du commerce et de l'industrie
qui sont autant de libertés
constitutionnelles c'est ainsi ce sont
des libertés constitutionnelles à
l'article 2 un amendement impose aux
entreprises la signature avant le 1er
janvier 2008 d'un accord cadre organisé
une procédure de prévention des conflits
cet article 2 marque une avancée vers
une nouvelle orientation de gestion des
conflits dans les grandes organisations
en effet il me semble que les sénateurs
ont souhaité rendre obligatoire et non
plus facultatif des négociations au
niveau de la branche
le débat d'aujourd'hui est donc
finalement une occasion contrairement à
ce qui a été dit ici de réhabiliter la
loi de 2007
cette loi n'est pas une négociation du
droit de grève
nulle part dans le texte il est écrit
que la loi excusez moi que la grève va
connaître des limites à part peut-être
en ce qui concerne les préavis glissant
ou à répétition
de fait le texte à une réalité et elle
cible trois éléments et ces éléments ne
peuvent être assimilés l imitation de ce
droit constitutionnel de grève la
prévention des conflits
via les négociations préalables
l'amélioration de la prévisibilité du
trafic et le renforcement de
l'information des usagers
pour autant on peut se poser la question
ces objectifs ont été remplis
la loi est-elle correctement appliquées
et c'est là l'objet de notre rencontre
aujourd'hui globalement on peut
considérer que la réponse est positive
même si le terme de globalement ne peut
masquer les manque d'application
constater les nouveaux outils du
dialogue social ont bien été mis en
oeuvre dans le secteur du transport
urbain avec la signature d'un accord de
branche
entre l'union des transports publics
uitp et organisons syndicales
représentatives le 3 décembre 2007
quant au processus d'élaboration des
plans de transport adapté pt a aidé plan
d'information des usagers pays eût il
semble désormais quasiment arrivé à son
terme
pourtant son application est encore
l'objet de polémiques de la part des
syndicats des employeurs des deux côtés
des griefs existe encore aujourd'hui du
côté des syndicats les salariés mettent
en exergue la faiblesse du dialogue
social celle des négociations préalables
de pure forme qui aboutissent le plus
souvent un constat de désaccord
je suis ravi de vous l'entendre dire du
côté employeur on reproche la loi de ne
pas traiter différemment les grèves
émanant de problèmes propres à
l'entreprise
c'est distinguo est très important des
grèves répondant à un mot d'ordre
national qui ne peut être satisfait par
l'entreprise
c'est le cas de la grève à laquelle on a
assisté ce soir
enfin un des mérites principale de ce
rapport et des souligné que
l'application de la loi connaît une
réelle faiblesse au niveau des processus
de dialogue en amont les recommandations
du rapport souligne que plus important
de mes appliquer la loi plutôt que
d'ajouter de nouvelles contraintes à
l'exercice du droit de grève
il préconise un approfondissement du
dialogue social actuellement
insuffisamment développé en dehors des
situations de conflit nous en avons une
très bonne illustration avec la grève
qui doit commencer ce soir je le répète
il nous apparaît important don de
répéter que le dialogue social doit être
une démarche permanente et non l'ultime
recours lorsque le conflit devient
inévitable enfin monsieur le ministre
je souhaite vous poser de questions
premièrement je voudrais savoir monsieur
le ministre
de quels moyens le gouvernement va se
doter pour assurer l'application
uniforme de la loi sur tout le
territoire
ma deuxième question est la suivante
quand et comment le ministère des
transports compte y est de recenser les
plans de transport adapté péter à
et les plans d'information d evp eu pour
obtenir ce qui me paraît totalement
indispensable un bilan exhaustif
en conclusion on peut considérer ce
rapport est en ligne droite avec
l'esprit de l'original mais on peut
également lire la volonté des sénateurs
d'insister sur le fait qu'aujourd'hui
dans une société en mutation imposée par
la force ou la contrainte ya tradiction
d'arrêter de travailler et moins
fructueux que de renforcer le dialogue
social afin que les conflits soient
traitées en amont mais le plus important
je crois et que ce rapport met un terme
aux postures purement politiciennes des
débats de 2007 où certains esprits mal
avisés avaient tenté de résumer ce débat
en une opposition entre défenseurs du
droit de grève et pourfendeur de ce même
droit ce rapport est donc le symbole
d'un débat qui arrive aujourd'hui à
maturité où chacun essaye d'apporter une
contribution en un mot ce rapport peut
être bien accueillie car il va alors et
la gestion des conflits concept tout à
fait actuelle et il s'inscrit totalement
dans tout management d'une entreprise du
21ème siècle et dirigeants nourrissent
souvent s'en inspirer pour désamorcer
les conflits sociaux débouchant sur des
grèves mais cet éclairage est il
suffisant il est difficile de trancher
car comme on l'a dit l'a dit mon
collègue vincent capo-canellas c'est
vrai la sncf réalise un dialogue social
en tout cas cet éclairage est une
avancée
qui ne peut malgré tout occulté les
autres problèmes merci la parole et à
madame mireille schurch pour le groupe
crc
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
madame et monsieur les cours à porter
mesdames et messieurs chers qui m'est
cher collègue pendant le président
nicolas sarkozy a entamé son mandat
présidentiel en 2007 en faisant adopter
une loi hautement symbolique abusivement
intitulé continuité du service public
dans les transports de voyageurs
il a clôturé ce même mandat en faisant
adopter par le parlement en mars 2012
une proposition de loi renforçant celle
de 2007 élargissant son périmètre
d'application au transport aérien
nous nous étions à l'époque sur
l'ensemble des bancs de la gauche
opposée à ces lois attentatoire au droit
de grève
en effet nous avions considéré à juste
titre qu'elle symbolisait parfaitement
l'esprit de la précédente mandature
un mépris des corps intermédiaires et la
volonté d'étouffer par la force
la colère sociale face aux politiques
ultra libérales menées alors les
élections présidentielle et législatives
de 2012 ont mis un terme à cette
orientation politique et à cette méthode
en plaçant à la tête de l'état une
nouvelle majorité sens et renouer un
dialogue respectueux et constructif avec
les organisations syndicales
pour cette raison nous avons déposé une
proposition de loi dès le 9 avril 2013
afin d'abroger au sein de ces lois les
dispositions que nous jugeons
attentatoire au droit de grève pour
cette raison également nous avons suivi
attentivement les travaux menés par la
mission sur l'état d'application de la
loi de 2007 qui est d'abord un bilan
nécessaires et porter d'évolutions
législatives
premièrement et c'est fondamental nous
partageons avec les rapporteurs l'idée
que le niveau de qualité du service
public n'est pas liée à l'exercice plus
ou moins importants du droit de grève
ainsi les grèves constituent et cela a
déjà été dit la part infime des
dysfonctionnements dans le secteur des
transports à hauteur de 3% selon le
rapport ce qui détériore quotidiennement
la qualité du service public de
or c'est bien l'application du dogme de
la concurrence
le manque de moyens humains et la
faiblesse la faiblesse des
investissements publics est au fond le
renoncement même à toute idée de service
public
au lieu de traiter les maux du service
public c'est loi démagogique se sont
contentés de détourner la colère des
usagers en les eaux en les opposant aux
salariés sans répondre à leurs attentes
légitimes en matière de services publics
une seule disposition aurait permis
d'améliorer service public il s'agit de
l'article 12 de la loi de 2007 issu de
l'adoption d'un amendement de notre
groupe qui impose l'incorporation de
clauses sociales et environnementales
dans les appels d'offres malheureusement
cette disposition n'a été appliquée qu'à
la marge
alors même que les rapporteurs ont
souligné son importance pour lutter
contre le recours à la sous-traitance
à ce titre je rappelle que dès l'examen
de cette loi
nous avions également proposé que les
groupes de transport public ne puisse
sous-traiter l'exercice des missions de
service public qui se voit confier sans
avoir procédé auparavant à une
négociation de nature à faire appliquer
les conditions sociales les plus
favorables
malheureusement cet amendement n'avait
pas pu être adoptée nous estimant
pourtant qu'une telle mesure reste une
piste de travail intéressante pour
améliorer la qualité de service et par
conséquent diminuer la conflictuelle it
et au sein des entreprises de transport
par ailleurs alors que la réforme
ferroviaire devrait être soumise au
parlement d'ici peu nous estimons
qu'elle devrait être l'occasion de poser
cette question essentielle de la
modernisation du service public et de
son financement
deuxième aspect de ce rapport les
conditions réelles d'exercice du droit
de grève aujourd'hui dans les
entreprises de transport
je rappelle que nous avons toujours
désigné comme je voulais objectifs réels
de ces lois celui de rendre plus
difficile exercice du droit de grève
reconnu constitutionnellement nous
partageons la zone corps les
préconisations du rapport qui propose la
suppression des dispositions
on introduit par la loi diar deux
déclarations individuelles de reprise du
travail qui complexifie rigidifie les
rapports entre salariés et employeurs
nous attendons positivement les
déclarations du secrétaire d'état aux
transports faisant un premier pas en ce
sens nous souhaitons pour notre part
allé plus loin en supprimant purement et
simplement toute obligation de
déclaration faite aux salariés grévistes
en effet ces déclarations d'un casse l
objet celui d'individualiser le rapport
des salariés à un mouvement collectif et
donc de les rendre plus vulnérables aux
pressions patronales
il en va de même pour la consultation
laissée à l'appréciation de l'employeur
au bout de huit jours de mouvement
social
d'ailleurs cette mesure reste difficile
d'application et même les organisations
patronales ont fait part au rapporteur
de la difficulté d'obtenir les
déclarations conduisant à ce que ce soit
parfois aux syndicats eux mêmes de faire
céder compte notre part comme le
souligne le rapport
ces procédés ont contribué à
judiciariser les rapports sociaux au
sein de l'entreprise ce qui à l'évidence
ne va pas dans le sens pourtant affiché
d'amélioration du dialogue social
troisièmement sur la création de plan de
transport adapté sur les plans
d'information des usagers
force est de constater une application
de la loi très inégale et l'absence
d'indicateur pour juger de l'intérêt de
ces dispositions
je regrette que l'obligation de
consultation des institutions
représentatives du personnel sur ses
plans avant leur approbation par
l'autorité organisatrice n'ait pas été
respecté enfin alors que les promoteurs
de cette loi en targuer de
l'instauration d'une information précise
et fiable sur la continuité de service
cette obligation n'est assortie d'aucune
sanction légale dans ces conditions
aucun progrès en la matière n'a donc pu
être réalisée le gouvernement avait
également prétendu que cette loi
permettrait d'améliorer
le dialogue social le rapport confirme
pourtant l'impossibilité d'affirmer que
l'instauration d'une sorte de préavis du
préavis par le dispositif d'alarmé
sociale est permis d'enrayer la
conflictuelle it et puisque si les
demandes de consultations immédiates ont
significativement augmenté les
dirigeants des entreprises continuent
d'attendre de constater l'état réel des
rapports de force avant d'engager toute
négociation or si le code du travail
précise d'ores et déjà que pendant la
durée du préavis les parties intéressées
sont tenus d négocier cette obligation
est souvent méconnue par les dirigeants
d'entreprises allonger la durée du temps
de négociation apparaît donc inutile si
rien ne contraint ces mêmes chefs
d'entreprise à se présenter à la table
des négociations avec des propositions
à ce titre le rapport note très
utilement que la procédure de prévention
des conflits se résume souvent à la
tenue à la tenue d'une unique réunion
entre la direction et les organisations
syndicales
ce qui ne nous paraît absolument pas
suffisant le rapport a également
démontré que ces dispositions sont
totalement inopérante lorsque la grève
répond à un appel national ou européen
interprofessionnelle ce qui représente
pourtant la plus grande conflictuelle it
et on l'a vu dans les grands projets
concernant les retraites et la
protection sociale
je me permet alors de formuler une idée
simple la clé de la paix sociale réside
au fond dans l'affirmation du choix de
politiques progressistes cessé de porter
atteinte aux acquis sociaux et aux
statuts cessé de d'inquiéter les
salariés sur leur avenir sont en effet
les plus sûrs moyens de réduire la conf
lituanie theo sein des entreprises et
notamment dans le secteur des transports
au regard des éléments de ce rapport
nous restons fonds persuadé qu afin de
restaurer la confiance avec les
partenaires sociaux il convient
d'abroger les dispositions de ces lois
dont les finalités
plus à voir avec la limitation d'un
droit constitutionnel
nous demandons officiellement
gouvernement d'inscrire à l'ordre du
jour la proposition de loi que nous
avons déposé en ce sens je finirai mes
chers collègues en vous rappelant que le
droit de grève et le droit ultime pour
les salariés dans la défense de leurs
droits et de leur outil de travail
je voudrais aussi rappeler que les
grèves menées par les ouvriers ont été
historiquement la voie la plus sûre pour
obtenir les plus belles avancées
sociales pour l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens alors plus que jamais le
droit de grève est un droit non
seulement constitutionnel mais un droit
fondamental pour notre démocratie qui
nous appartient de protéger je vous
remercie
merci ma chère collègue dernier orateur
monsieur michel teston pour le groupe
socialiste
monsieur le président sur le ministre
chères et chers collègues et notamment
madame et monsieur les rapporteurs de la
commission est la loi du 21 août 2007
constitue l'une des premières lois
emblématiques du quinquennat de nicolas
sarkozy
elle témoigne d'une vision clivante
voire populiste de la société vision
selon laquelle en faisant valoir leurs
droits certains citoyens prendre en
otages d'autres citoyens
après les effets d'un an souvent un peu
démagogique
le texte présenté en procédure accélérée
a été largement édulcoré par rapport aux
intentions affichées initialement par
nicolas sarkozy ainsi le texte adopté
comporte une disposition phare qui vise
à permettre la mise en oeuvre d'un
service garanti en cas de grève ou de
perturbations prévisibles et définies
par les autorités organisatrices de
transport en fonction des spécificités
locales
pour cela deux mesures ont été mises en
place premièrement l'obligation pour les
salariés de déclarer 48 heures avant le
début de la grève s'ils ont l'intention
d'y participer et seconde main la
possibilité après huit jours de grève
d'organiser à l'initiative de
l'employeur ou d'une organisation
syndicale
un vote indicatif à bulletin secret sur
la poursuite ou non du ouvre les autres
dispositions du texte ont prévu
l'encadrement de l'organisation de la
négociation collective près al de la
grève et l'information des usagers lors
du débat parlementaire sur ce texte je
me suis opposé à son adoption
comme d'ailleurs les autres membres du
groupe socialiste considérant que sous
couvert d'une volonté affichée
d'améliorer le dialogue social
cette loi n'avait comme objectif que de
limiter l'exercice du droit de grève
j'ai d'ailleurs souligné à l'époque que
la mise en place
d'un service minimum revenait à
privilégier un droit essentiel par
rapport à un autre en l'occurrence la
continuité du service public sur le
droit de grève comme d'ailleurs l'avait
très bien démontré en son temps c'était
en 2004 le rapport mandelkern en outre
sur le plan organique organisationnel la
mise en place d'un service minimum site
à mon avis de procéder à des
réquisitions de personnel en effet pour
assurer ce service
il est probablement nécessaire disposer
du concours de 80% du personnel
ceci étant mon opposition à ce texte
aurait été encore plus forte si il avait
autorisé le recours à cette procédure
or cette loi n'a pas imposé la
réquisition cette idée est resté très
présente chez certains parlementaires de
la majorité présidentielle de l'époque
et j'en veux pour preuve le dépôt en
février 2009
la proposition de loi d'eric ciotti
visant à mettre en place un droit de
réquisition proposition de loi qui n'a
heureusement pas été adopté en somme
avec cette loi
il s'est agi de trouver le coupable
idéal des nombreux retards que subissent
au quotidien les usagers des transports
sont ainsi les agents du service public
qui ont été montrés du doigt pourtant ce
sont les choix d'investissements
effectués par les gouvernements
précédents conduisant à pro privilégier
le déroulement du réseau à grande
vitesse au détriment de la rénovation du
réseau existant qui explique en grande
partie les dysfonctionnements c'est
pourquoi a lâché de la remise des
conclusions de la commission mobilité 21
présidé par philippe duron le
gouvernement héros a décidé de
privilégier les trains du quotidien
marquant ainsi un tournant en matière de
priorité pour les investissements
publics dans le domaine des transports
alors ce choix me paraît responsable il
ne s'agit pas de renoncer à compléter le
réseau ferroviaire à grande vitesse mais
de le développer en fonction des
capacités contributives
mais c'est bien désormais l'amélioration
des transports du quotidien qui est mise
en pour nous
appuyant sur une logique qui pourrait
être qualifié de répressif et
accusatrices la loi du 21 août 2007 ne
pouvait que produire de médiocres en
effet c'est d'ailleurs ce que montre le
bilan de cette loi réalisé par isabelle
pasquet et marque la mine en effet même
si cette loi repose sur un équilibre
complexe qui a permis de développer
progressivement des habitudes de
négociation collective
elle n'a convaincu personne me syndicats
ni employeur il ya même parfois pu
générer des dysfonctionnements dans la
continuité du service public par exemple
le mécanisme d'encadrement de la grève
prévues par cette loi a contribué à
crisper les positions avec d'un côté des
salariés dissuader de faire grève
et d'un autre côté des employeurs qui
subiraient selon heureux des recours
abusif à la négociation collective
praslin alors au final quels résultats
pour l'usager si cette loi est
incontestablement améliorer
l'information du public sur les
circulations prévisible en cas de
perturbation du trafic
les éléments de l'analyse manque pour
établir précisément une corrélation
entre l'application de cette loi et
l'évolution de la conflictuelle it et
dans les entreprises de transport
en effet les motifs de grève ne sont pas
toujours liés à des problèmes internes
aux entreprises de transport ce sont
parfois des mots d'ordre nationaux qui
sont à l'origine des mobilisations
par ailleurs ce manque d'éléments
d'analysé n'a pas permis de récolter des
informations suffisantes pour mettre en
avant la part des incidents techniques
quotidiens et les mouvements de grève
dans la gestion des transports publics
même si l'on sait que le mauvais état de
certaines lignes conduit régulièrement à
des retards en effet si l'on demandé
aujourd'hui aux utilisateurs des
transports publics si cette loi a eu un
impact positif sur déplacements
journaliers
il n'est pas impossible que la réponse
ne sont pas positives
c'est pourquoi la préconisation du
rapport concernant l'irlande outils
statistiques harmonisées du suivi de la
loi me semble pertinent
il en est de même de la recommandation
de renforcer le dialogue social des
entreprises de transport y compris en
dehors des périodes conflictuelle il
s'agit bien du meilleur service à rendre
aux usagers en effet si la loi doit
fixer les conditions d'exercice du droit
de grève
elle ne peut et ne doit pas tout fixer
une large place doit être laissée à la
concertation et à la négociation dans
chaque entreprise comme le propose aussi
les rapporteurs il est logique de
sensibiliser les à ôter à la définition
de desserte prioritaires ainsi qu'à
l'approbation de périmètre de transport
adapté et de plan d'information aux
usagers
enfin il convient de ne pas oublier qu
une politique d'investissements au
niveau sur le réseau dit classique est
probablement le meilleur moyen de
réduire sensiblement les retards subis
au quotidien et donc d'améliorer
d'assurer pardon une meilleure
continuité du service public dans les
transports terrestres
dans cette optique doter la fille de
moyens suffisants et donc également au
coeur de ce débat c'est à mon sens par
la conjugaison de ces différentes
préconisations que l'on n'atteindra le
fragile mais il sert équilibre entre la
garantie de la continuité du service
public et la protection du principe de
valeur constitutionnelle du droit de
vous merci mon cher collègue la parole
est à monsieur frédéric cuvillier
secrétaire d'état chargé des transports
de la mer et de la pêche
ok
merci monsieur le président madame
monsieur les rapporteurs messieurs les
sénatrices et sénateurs
tiens tout d'abord à mon tour adressé
tous mes remerciements à vous madame la
sénatrice isabelle pasquet à vous
monsieur le sénateur marc laménie pour
la qualité du rapport tout le monde y
fait référence rapport sur l'application
des dispositions de la loi du 21 août
2007 relative à la continuité du service
public dans les transports terrestres de
voyageurs j'ai entendu je prends note de
l'ensemble des contributions apportées
par les groupes parlementaires sur ce
sujet qui est important et vous avez par
ce rapport permis le débat indispensable
sur la tente des usagers nos concitoyens
de la qualité des services publics la
continuité principe même des services
publics mais dans le même temps
également qui permet d'assurer aussi des
conditions d'exercice de grève --les est
importante pour nous pour vous de
veiller à ce que cet exercice d'un rêve
plus d'abord être précédé d'un certain
nombre de garanties sur la qualité du
dialogue social est précisément c'est de
la qualité de ce dialogue social dont
dépend la suite de ce que la relation
entre employeurs et employés
amen et de pouvoir éviter toute
situation de blocage souvent dénoncée et
parfois permettant à certains comme cela
a été rappelé et l'histoire n'est pas si
ancienne d'essayer de faire en sorte que
l'antagonisme des situations amène à
l'antagonisme des personnes et que les
usagers
né un devoir regretté l'exercice de
revendications et souvent sont légitimes
rarement je n'ai rencontré deux
personnes exerçant un droit de grève de
façon volontaire sont même qu'il y ait
de base de sérieux alors qu'en est il
aujourd'hui après cette année
d'application
quel est le bilan de la loi 2007 les
positions sont diverses je les ai
entendu un devoir de réhabilitation qui
a été demandée souhaité par madame masse
au marais de cette loi de 2005 jusqu'à
l'abrogation de dispositions réclamées
par madame cher et on voit là toute la
palette et la diversité de
l'appréciation de cette loi qui si elle
ne fait plus débat dans les conditions
dans laquelle elle faisait débat même
s'il est nécessaire que l'on puisse
appréhender les dispositions les
actualiser éventuellement c'est vrai que
les conditions dans lesquelles elle le
fut annoncée ne permettait pas d'avoir
un débat des plus sereins vous en
conviendrez sur robert pu rappeler cette
période avec beaucoup de la part des
auteurs de la part des défenseurs de ce
texte d'effets de manche qui a eu pour
effet de priver durablement le coeur
même du dispositif au profit de posture
politique
mais ce qui est vrai c'est que il reste
pour autant un dispositif qui est un
dispositif de prévention et de
résolution des situations conflictuelles
et que le coeur de cette noire et de son
application doit être la négociation
préalable est suffisant doit-on en
améliorer le dispositif
vous avez les uns les autres au fil de
vos interventions amener quelques
illustrations qui ne sera utile de
reprendre en son temps et puis par
ailleurs l'information le droit de
l'usagé est en effet de pouvoir parce
que les vertus même du service public le
perçu de vertu même de transport
de voyageurs doit nous permettre
d'assurer cela à l'usagé d'avoir en cas
de perturbations prévisibles mis en
place le plan de transport adapté le
plan d'information des usagers vont le
voir un équilibre qui est un équilibre
précaire et s'agissant de la prévention
de la résolution des conflits
la ratp et ce fut dès 1996 la sncf dès
2003 avaient chacune conclu un protocole
d'accord prévoyant un dispositif
d'alerté sociale similaire d'ailleurs à
celui introduit par la loi c'est à dire
que parfois il n'est pas nécessaire
d'avoir recours à la loi et qu'il est au
contraire de la responsabilité de chacun
des acteurs de pouvoir amener des
dispositifs qui appelle au dialogue et
aux dispositions pré contentieux c'est
donc cette référence qui nous amène
comme le souligne votre rapport à ce que
avant l'entrée en vigueur de cette loi
la conclusion des accords relever d'un
simple engagement moral de signature de
la part des signataires qui n'avait pas
de valeur obligatoire qui n'avait qu'à
caractère facultatif et toutes les
entreprises ne s'en sont pas dotés or le
dispositif de négociation préalable est
à mon sens essentiel je le rappelais
foyer sénateurs de ce soir à prouver
opiné du chef et bien oui il est
indispensable que nous puissions avoir
ces dispositifs mais le dialogue doit
être la clé de voûte des rapports
sociaux entre dirigeants et salariés par
la voix du sénateur jacques bernard
magner sur un solide indiqué qu'il était
difficile de mesurer l'impact de la loi
sur la confiture alité on peut malgré
tout si on s'y engager la loi impose
désormais le dialogue dans toutes les
entreprises
et je pense que cela est une bonne chose
et que tous les lieux qui permettront de
donnez exercice est de favoriser ce
dialogue doit être organisé et conforté
il y a eu un certain nombre de chiffres
adam pasquet madame la reporter indiqué
qu'il n'était pas suffisamment
pertinents monsieur considérer pour leur
part qu'ils ne la portait pas
d'amélioration sensible revanche
d'autres chiffres peuvent vous en avez
cité le sénateur d'autres chiffres
peuvent aussi prêter à interprétation je
pense notamment la situation de la ratp
où le nombre de préavis de grève
entre 2004 et 2007 était situé entre 173
et 367 et après 2007 s'est situé entre
36 et 59
donc il y à une réalité je partage votre
constat qui est partagé ici de la part
d'un certain nombre de d'intervenants
sur la nécessité d'y voir plus clair sur
l'impact et sur les réalités des effets
de cette loi
s'agissant suite de l'information des
voyageurs la loi impose qu'une
information sur la circulation
prévisibles fois mises en place en amont
des perturbations annoncées du trafic
cette information tout le monde en
convient ce test on le rappeler à
l'instant tout le monde en convient
représente un net progrès et c'est même
une forme de respect que l'on doit aux
usagers du service public de transport
en commun et même comme l'ont signalé à
la fois c'est le rapporteur sassard et
conflits sociaux ne représente mais
également d'autres intervenants ne
représentent qu'une minorité et c'est
important de pouvoir le rappeler et vous
l'avez dit une minorité des
perturbations car souvent cette ce sont
ces conflits sociaux qui sont mises en
avant pour dénoncer
et parfois stigmatisées de l'image si
une matiz et la réalité même des
services publics non les perturbations
saute d'autres de la part d'autres faits
générateurs et vous invitiez a plaidé
sur la nécessité pour le transport de
bénéficier des moyens nécessaires la
modernisation rénovation et notamment
dans le ferroviaire je ne puis ici que
vous exprimer la sensibilité qui est la
mienne de pouvoir obtenir les modalités
d'un financement pérenne permettant de
relever les objectifs et les priorités
du transport du quotidien et nous aurons
dans quelques jours ici un débat riche
même si en d'autres lieux il est déjà
engagée concernant la nécessité pour
l'état de redonner des priorités à la
structuration à une stratégie qu une
politique de transport indispensable
mais donc l'information disais je est
indispensable elle doit être une
garantie livré aux usagers nous pouvons
le constater aujourd'hui puisque la sncf
a publié dès hier soir un état précis de
ce que sera le trafic dans le cadre de
la grève qui est prévu pour la journée
de demain
monsieur capo-canellas souligné oui
c'est dans ce contexte que nous avons
sept ce débat mais se dire aussi que
nous pouvons souligner nous pouvons
apprécier combien
le dispositif peut apporter en
prévisibilité le bilan au bout de ses 7
ans semble de ce point de vue positif la
loi a permis de trouver un équilibre
les rapporteurs en conviennent tout en
le qualifiant de complexe et fragile un
équilibre entre les valeurs qui sont des
valeurs constitutionnelles continuité du
service public de transport l'exercice
du droit de grève
toutefois je partage les préoccupations
et la préoccupation des rapporteurs
selon laquelle il faut que nous
puissions mieux tirer parti des
possibilités offertes par la loi
notamment en matière d'association des
partenaires sociaux et dans le cadre
d'un dialogue social approfondi ce la
première préoccupation de votre rapport
et c'est vrai que c'est un enjeu qui
doit nous amener à faire en sorte que la
négociation préalable instaurée par la
loi soit utilisée de façon adopte
d'adapter et qu'il ne s'agisse pas de la
dernière procédure peut être d'une
formalité purement administrative je
reprends auxquels vos propos madame le
rapporteur et le la tête au contraire un
une et cela doit être une étape d'un
véritable processus visant à éviter le
conflit avait pas une formalité je le
disais elle doit au contraire construire
un véritable accord entre les différents
partenaires
d'une façon plus générale et c'est le
sens de la seconde préoccupé
préconisations il me semble que nous
devons mettre au coeur et inscrire au
coeur de l'ensemble de management des
entreprises
la notion de dialogue social et de faire
en sorte que nous puissions accompagner
les évolutions du transport terrestre à
en mettant l'ensemble des procédures
adaptées pour favoriser ce dialogue
social vous avez là encore souligné
madame la rapporteure les organisations
syndicales ne peut pas être simplement
reçu uniquement lors de dépôt d'un
préavis
mais au contraire doivent être des
partenaires d'un dialogue répéter
s'agissant des deux principales
reprise relevant du champ de la loi de
2007 la sncf et la ratp il existe des
observatoires sociaux paritaire qui se
réunissent annuellement pour établir un
bilan des relations sociales dans
l'entreprise
c'est un bilan qui est rendu public et
les membres de ces observatoires émettre
des propositions d'amélioration du
dialogue social tire des conséquences
lors de conflits et le gouvernement ne
peut qu'inviter les entreprises à
développer ce type de démarche vertueuse
s'agissant de la loi du 19 mars 2012
cette fois dite loi diar je remercie
monsieur capot canelas d'avoir bien
préciser le cadre du rapport mais vous
l'aviez là aussi indiqué la portée du
rapport le lien qui peut y avoir entre
les deux les deux dispositions
législatives les deux lois le concernant
pour ce qui nous concerne pour ce qui
vous concerne que les dispositions
communes aux transports terrestres pour
autant nécessaire d'en dire deux mots je
ne reviendrai pas plus longtemps ça a
été fait admirablement bien madame
cherche sur les conditions dans
lesquelles la loi a été mise en
discussion de façon soudaine
sans concertation sur robert hue il a
également indiqué et rappeler dans quel
contexte nous étions fin de mandature de
la précédente majorité
là aussi quel est son bilan elle a été
jugée constitutionnelle en mars 2012
et il est vrai que sa mise en place à
imposer bon nombre de contraintes
administratives blum tant pour les
salariés que pour les employeurs
ces derniers ont parfois dû déployer
d'importants moyens pour la mise en
place d'outils adaptés
aujourd'hui son application est
stabilisé une application qui en
revanche je tiens à être précis ne
saurait justifier d'aucune façon une
atteinte à l'exercice fondamental du
droit de grève
et c'est la raison pour laquelle il ya
encore quelques semaines je me suis
engagé dans le secteur aérien par
exemple a rencontré
les compagnies aériennes afin de leur
demander fermement des engagements
clairs de bonne conduite et éviter
d'éventuels détournements des
dispositions législatives c'est dans le
cet esprit que je souhaite faire évoluer
l'application de la loi du 19 mars 2012
j'ai entendu qu'un rapport d'application
pouvait être demandé
la commission bien évidemment nous
suivrons cette procédure parlementaire
avec beaucoup d'intérêt vous préconisez
ensuite madame monsieur le rapporteur de
responsabiliser les autorités
organisatrices de transport aot t en les
sensibilisant notamment à la définition
des dessertes prioritaire à
l'approbation des périmètres de
transports adaptés au plan d'information
des usagers je partage cette
préoccupation elles ont été exprimées
par bon nombre d'entre vous et des
différents intervenants
c'est vrai que des actions de
sensibilisation des a ôté quant à leurs
obligations en matière de défini de
définition des plans de transport de
plan d'information devront être engagée
dès lors qu'un bilan plus approfondie de
l'application de la loi aura pu être
réalisée par les services de l'état j'ai
entendu vos questions solennel madame la
sénatrice madame masson marais le
demandant d'apporter informations aux
parlementaires je le ferai dès lors que
les services auront pu avoir les
informations suffisamment solides pour
en tirer conséquent je réponds ainsi
aussi au sens de votre recommandation
numéro 9 nuls relatives à un recensement
de ces plans madame monsieur les
rapporteurs nécessaires pour obtenir un
bilan exhaustif de l'application de la
loi nous manquons de données à ce niveau
vous le soulignez et je fais mienne
c'est préoccupant
ces préconisations des enquêtes
annuelles sont aujourd'hui réalisées sur
l'activité des transports publics
urbains départementaux régionaux
elles sont engagées par le ministère des
transports en partenariat avec un
certain nombre d'acteurs c'est vrai de
garde c'est vrai de la grève
c'est vrai de la dette
vrai de l'utp fntv de l'anateep bref je
proposerai de compléter toutes les
enquêtes qui peuvent être engagées par
des questions sur le plan de transport
adapté sur le plan d'information des
usagers concernant votre cinquième
préconisations consistant à intégrer des
critères sociaux et environnementaux
préconisations relayé par madame cherche
2 dans le cadre de qualité de service
dans les conventions d'exploitation tel
que prévu à l'article 12 de la loi
il est vrai que le contenu des
conventions d'exploitation relève de la
responsabilité de chacune des à ôter
pour autant il est important que nous
puissions rappelé l'intégration
nécessaire de critères sociaux de ces
critères environnementaux également de
qualité service qui aujourd'hui ne sont
que trop variables et insuffisamment
stabiliser des préconisations du rapport
en la matière me semble être un bon
point d'appui nous permettant de
renforcer les bonnes pratiques dans ce
domaine
s'agissant des conventions ter entre les
régions et la sncf celles ci ont été
signés avant la loi de 2007
elles peuvent intégrer des clauses
relatives à la qualité de service ainsi
que la communication d'information des
voyageurs mais elle ne possède pas de
critères sociaux et environnementaux en
tant que tel les conventions suivantes
traite ces critères de façon variable
je donnerai des bons points la
convention du ter limousin signé en 2012
certainement une des plus abouties avec
un titre spécifique sur le développement
durable et solidaire traitant des
relations avec des usagers de
l'accessibilité de la prévention des
impacts sur l'environnement
je peux citer également la dernière
convention avec la région franche comté
qui pourrait voir pour sa part des
dispositions de nature à favoriser
l'insertion sociale
on le voit les initiatives sont en passe
d'être prise et l'application de la loi
plus précise s'agissant des trains
d'équilibré du territoire madame la
reporter indiqué quel état était en
retard ou c'était madame recherche mais
vous avez
souvent la même voie et donc je reprends
cet ce propos l'état est l'autorité
organisatrice depuis le 1er janvier 2011
la convention d'exploitation d'une durée
initiale de trois ans a été prorogée en
décembre de l'an dernier de l'année
dernière et l'élaboration de la
convention s'inscrit dans le respect des
dispositions de la loi en incitant par
exemple la sncf a amélioré le report
modal ce sera indispensable en prévoyant
un dispositif de bonus malus sur la
qualité de service et j'ai introduit
l'interpellation
les rapporteurs j'ai souhaité j'ai
souhaité négocier et que l'état négocié
avec la sncf le contenu de la prochaine
convention d'exploitation qui prendra
effet à partir de 2015 sur la base des
préconisations qui sont les vôtres et
dans le cadre de ces discussions nous
veillerons à promouvoir de plus grandes
exigences envers l'exploitant c'est vrai
par exemple de l'implication plus forte
demande et à la sncf sur les enjeux liés
à la quantité de liés à la continuité de
service public à l'information des
voyageurs
c'est vrai également de l'attention
portait la définition et au respect des
plans de transport adapté pour d'autres
situations de perturbations que les
seules grève auquel il est fait trop
souvent référence en matière
environnementale il pourra être tiré les
premiers les bénéfices du renouvellement
du matériel roulant vous savez combien
le gouvernement s'est impliqué dans
cette orientation pour pouvoir tout
simplement en termes de report modal de
réduction de la consommation d'énergie
sur les premières lignes qui en
bénéficieront veut pouvoir tirer plein
de conséquence de l'impulsion qui a été
donné par le gouvernement
c'est vrai notamment du matériel du
nouveau matériel bi-mode à partir de
2016 et de l'ensemble des conventions et
de l'envelope arrêté par le premier
ministre il y à plus d'un an une
enveloppe de 510 millions de
renouvellement des tmt madame la
rapporteure
le rapporteur vous demander par ailleurs
de systématiser les contrôles des bilans
d'exécution des plans de transport de
transport adapté les plans d'information
des usagers car les retours d'expérience
auprès des a ôté sont aujourd'hui quasi
inexistant je tiens à rappeler qu'il est
prévu que après chaque perturbations
l'entreprise de transport communiqué la
haute t un bilan détaillé de l'exécution
du plan de transport adapté également du
plan d'information des usagers
l'entreprise doit donc évaluer chaque
année les incidences financières de
l'exécution de ces plans dresser la
liste des investissements nécessaires à
l'amélioration de leur mise en oeuvre et
le contrôle de ces bilan d'exécution
relève de chaque côté s'agissant de
l'état la prochaine convention
d'exploitation des trains d'équilibré du
territoire
elle devrait également permettre de
renforcer l'encadrement des retours
aujourd'hui 13 informel de l'exploitant
à l'autorité organisatrice qu'on le dit
que l'état doit être de nouveau de
retour je la digue dans la réforme
ferroviaire
eh bien nous avons là aussi une exigence
qui est une exigence de l'état
autoritaire organisatrice dix ans de
transport qui doit obtenir les
informations de la bonne exécution des
adaptations annoncé pour terminer le
rapport préconise le développement
d'outils drastique statistiques pardon
harmonisé de suivi de l'application de
la loi
nous en sommes d'accord chacun a indiqué
mais ces tests ont également l'absence
de fiabilité statistique concernant
l'application de la loi il nous faut
donc mettre en place des indicateurs
indicateurs public consolidé de mesure
et de suivi des cause de perturbations
de trafic sncf je pense que c'est le
meilleur moyen de pouvoir apporter
réponse notamment lorsque nous sommes en
situation de conflit à une forme de
l'image d'epinal sûr
conflictuelles ite et les perturbations
sociales
bon nombre de nos usagers attendent de
nous de la régularité mais encore
faut-il qu'ils aient bien connaissance
fait qu' un certain nombre de retards
sont générés par des plans de
modernisation de lignes par
effectivement ce sénateur robert hue
indiqué ce qu'on appelle des accidents
de personne et qui sont pourtant des
réalités beaucoup plus dramatique que le
nom employé ou la périphrase donc il est
important que nous puissions éclairer
livré l'information de sorte que nous ne
soyons pas dans une forme d'eau propre
populaire contre telle ou telle
difficulté d'application du service
public et peut-être de raccourcis
médiatiques un peu souvent la réalité de
reportages ou d'information en continu
nous devons assurer la diffusion au
grand public des données statistiques
sur la régularité on se rendrait compte
que la régularité certainement beaucoup
plus élevé la ponctualité beaucoup plus
élevé que les tendances sont à
l'amélioration malgré une situation
extrêmement des craintes dégradé un
certain nombre de témoignages sont venus
là aussi rapporté le fait que la
priorité donnée ces dernières années aux
lignes grande vitesse ce testons est
intarissable sur la question fait que
quatre lignes lgv était élancé en même
temps alors que le rythme de réalisation
est plutôt d'une ligne lgv tous les six
ans la soutenabilité financière amène à
7 e il y est eu des priorités retenues
qui n'était pas celle attendue de la
part de nos concitoyens nous en sommes
aujourd'hui nous sommes confrontés à
cette réalité il nous faut là aussi
donner tout tout rayonnement à
l'autorité de la qualité de service dans
les transports qui a été créée le 15
février 2012
cette entité administrative qui
s'intéresse à tous les modes de
transport public de voyageurs
et pour le coup y compris l'aérien le
ferroviaire le routier le maritime
s'appuie sur un haut comité de laquelle
et du service dans les transports qui
rassemble depuis mai 2013 sous la
présidence du député olivier faur 37
représentants des acteurs de tous les
modes de transport public de voyageurs
et qui permet qu'il s'agisse de
collectivités d'opérateurs
d'associations que le consommateur ou
d'usagé de publier des taux d'annulation
de retard des principales liaisons
aériennes de toutes les liaisons tgv
d'été le thé par mois par liaison et
pour l'aérien par compagnie a encore
certainement beaucoup d'améliorations
apportées mais c'est une voie
intéressante et la publication de ces
taux mensuel d'annulation les retards de
tt globalisé pour toutes les liaisons
ferroviaires d'une même région et des
taux de ponctualité voyageurs des lignes
des huit lignes de chacune des huit
lignes de transilien des cinq lignes rer
sont des garanties supplémentaires que
nous pouvons apporter
il manque cependant à ces chiffres une
analyse l'analyse des causes et cela a
été souligné
nous ne disposons pas aujourd'hui
suffisamment de d'information la sncf
dispose de données quantitatives par
axes tgv et pour les lignes intercités
mais pas les a ôté régional pour les
perturbations de leur ter
c'est à dire que nous n'avons que de
façon parcellaire les informations
relatives au ferroviaire la dg à st
disposent elles des données codifié
selon une nomenclature internationale
qui est extrêmement détaillées il faut
un recueil des données qui soit deux
derniers des données exhaustives
homogène pour obtenir un tableau de bord
national cohérent qui permettent
d'identifier les mesures prioritaires
c'est d'ailleurs un guide qui pourraient
là aussi être extrêmement pertinent sur
les débats et le parlement sera appelé à
retrouver une forme d'impulsions du
débat dans les politiques de transport
que nous souhaitons et bien de pouvoir
identifier les mesures prioritaires à
mettre en oeuvre pour améliorer la
qualité le service aux voyageurs
c'est pourquoi la qst a proposé le 15
mai 2014 d'étudier en concertation avec
les opérateurs avec les autorités avec
cinq catégories avec l'ensemble des
acteurs sac catégorie simple de cause de
perturbations valable pour tous les
mômes les modes de transport et nous
permettant d'objectiver les causes
vous avez raison madame monsieur les
rapporteurs d'affirmer qu'il ya trop
d'idées reçues elles sont erronées et
que une approche qui puisse être la plus
scientifique et objective nous
permettrait certainement de d'apporter
informations et réalité sur l'évolution
de la qualité de transport je serai
attentif à ces avancées
car c'est aussi une crédibilité même des
conditions de crédibilité du service
public des transports
pour finir je partage la position selon
laquelle il conviendrait que les
partenaires sociaux de la branche des
entreprises de transport interurbain
conclu un accord sur le modèle de celui
en vigueur dans le transport urbain
c'est un exercice qui n'est pas toujours
simple car le savez la branche est
composé d'une multiplicité de petites
entreprises dans lesquelles les
dispositions mises en oeuvre à les
grandes entreprises de transport urbain
pas nécessairement transposable il
facile à mettre en oeuvre et il le
faudra que nous puissions regarder dans
quelle mesure adaptées ce dispositif
voilà aussi une un domaine dans lequel
l'état devra jouer son rôle de
facilitateur dans ce dialogue je tiens
une fois encore à saluer votre rapport
qui nous permet de poursuivre le
continuer ce débat nécessaire sur les
conditions d'exercice de droit de grève
revendiquée mais également de continuité
de service public de la qualité même de
service public
c'est vrai que l'actualité vient en
quelque sorte illustrer la préoccupation
qui est la vôtre qui est la nôtre et
de pouvoir aussi permettre de valoriser
les bonnes pratiques de d'objectiver les
données et les bonnes informations
ce qui ne pourra que donner une image
une crédibilité à l'ensemble de
l'activité du transport public est
nécessairement redorer la nécessaire
images de ce service public qui était
garant l'égalité des territoires mais
aussi l'égalité des chances sur ces
territoires ce service public qui est
une réalité nationale à la française
mais qui est au coeur de notre
discussion lorsque nous rencontrons les
instances européennes
j'ai eu l'occasion de le rappeler à mon
homologue monsieur lupi qui dans
quelques jours présidera le conseil des
ministres européens nous devons aborder
l'enjeu de l'organisation des transports
avec cette réalité et les territoriales
elle est humaine
elle est humaine pour les salariés elle
est humaine pour les usagers c'est cette
réalité de ces grandes lois qui fondent
la réalité du service public auquel nous
sommes attachés
merci merci monsieur le ministre nous en
avons donc terminé avec le débat sur le
dialogue social et la continuité du
service public dans les transports
terrestres réguliers de voyageurs
voilà vous avez donc pu suivre ce débat
sur les effets de la loi de 2007 sur le
service minimum dans les transports
tout de suite la suite de nos programmes
sur public sénat
[Musique]